so the the the story is number one Beal
and Booker they look good they get it
done the second story is what's going to
happen to Draymond Green now it was
staggering to see I think we're all kind
of asking ourselves is this going to
happen again what is your first thought
when you see that with Draymond and
nurkic well a lot of things first of all
it's disappointing because this team is
struggling and this team is trying to
figure it out they're 4- 10 in the last
you know going into this game the last
14 games they need Draymond on the court
they need his defense they need his
leadership they need the confidence and
the Swagger he brings the team to the
team but they don't need this because
this will ultimately lead to a
suspension and considering his track
record and considering what's transpired
this year he may be more than five games
in terms of you know compared to what he
had before and so you just you dig in a
hole and you seem to not be able to get
out out of that hole and you know he's
got to use better judgment in that
situation um he is too important and too
valuable to this team and this this is a
a team that's had great success and and
they're getting older and they're still
fighting to stay in the mix but we're
seeing a decline here and let's just be
honest and we know Charles has talked
about it sure and and maybe some of that
is lashing out that lashing out is
frustration because you can see the
writing on the wall I'm only speculating
and saying that but you know this this
can't happen you know a month from when
the last incident happened and I expect
it'll be you know some serious time
missed for for Draymond again this
Warriors team started 6-2 they're 4- 11
since and now I'm realizing tonight was
a microcosm of that struggle Draymond
ejection Klay Thompson seven points on
two of 10 shooting this was carried the
warriors were only in this game because
of that bench how do you figure out the
Draymond peace but also the Klay
Thompson piece I mean it's he wasn't in
there in crunch time no he was not in in
there crunch time and that's that was my
question off airs like what do you do
right now with Clay what what what
happens and I I
think the Warriors of old is not there
and I think you think you add Chris Paul
now it changes how their offens is run
at one point Steph was the point guard
Clay's coming off of those screens now
that's not the case CP is pretty much
doing that now Steph in either one or
the other so it's just changed their
offense they're struggling so on and so
forth
so I don't know I don't know what
happens here I agree with you Dre
Draymond will more than likely get more
than five games because of the recent
history right um but they need him they
need his voice they need his voice on
the offensive defensive
end I don't know you can't make those
mistakes a loss for word makes sense at
this point I love Draymond of Def but to
be honest with you there's no place for
that in the game like I was looking to
see what nerkish did to Warrant that and
it was a normal defensive play yeah like
it wasn't like there was some you know
that from what we see it wasn't like
there was something else to happen that
you know kind of Warrant at that so I
don't think there's a place for it in
the game obviously I think the
suspension is coming but as the Warriors
you look at them they're not the same
Warriors they were but everybody else
has gotten better mhm the warriors were
the king of Randomness they didn't need
plays they needed IQ and the way they
play and their shot making it made
things great for everybody else where
other teams took a page out of that book
but they're younger and they're hungry
you know what I mean as well so their
room for error is like this now when it
was a wide wide margin and I think
that's what's kind of but the question
is I I think is how do you get clay out
of this slump because right at this
point he's so important to the success
you know Clay used to be able to get
separation to get open now some of it I
think Jamal to your point point it was
how they played they played fast they
got up and down there was paced at the
way they moved in the half court a lot
of stuff now with Clay like he's not
open he doesn't have that kind of
Separation every shot is a difficult
contested shot and so you know they
they've they've gotten older and you
know you bring in Chris Paul who's been
fantastic and has played off the bench
has started has been a number of things
but the they just they're more they're
slower they don't get up and down don't
play with that same Pace the second unit
actually plays with that pace I was
going to ask you that would you bring
him off the bench to have him go against
second unit guys to have him get some
easy baskets and get in Rhythm that way
feature him a little more yes and
feature him where he's the number one
guy on the second unit look one of the
hardest things and and you know I guess
I did it you know Vince did it when
you've been at a certain level right and
you've been at an Elite All-Star level
and then Father Time catches up can can
you humble yourself to transform your
game are you willing to now not be that
guy but still be a productive guy for
your ball club now you know and that may
be where Clay is trying to figure out
and making that transition look he's had
I think he had five 20po games in the
last 10 games including to tonight so he
has picked up his scoring from the early
part of the season but he just can't
consistently do it day in and day out
and and you know F father not everybody
can be LeBron James you know and I say
that you know you know respectfully that
he's still doing it at a high level at
his age but you know the problem is he's
not defending like he used to and maybe
because of the injuries that was an area
where he had value and then he's not
offensively if he's not catching and
shooting and making shots he's not
giving you as much or as what you need
out there on the court on that side of
the ball Draymond Green will not be
speaking to the media tonight however
Steve Kerr will
be